let's talk about guns we talked about
guns a little bit in the aftermath of
the incident at Fort Lauderdale Airport
over the weekend on yesterday's show I
want to talk about this horrible reality
that on the one hand the US continues to
be riddled with gun crime on the other
hand there are other countries developed
countries first world countries that are
not having gun crime issues for example
Japan which has one of the lowest rates
of gun crime in the world now to talk
about the raw numbers in 2014
Japan had this is not a typo this is not
me miss speaking
six-six gun deaths compared to this is
sad thirty three thousand five hundred
and ninety-nine in the united states now
before we go further I know people will
say David Japan and the US have
different populations so we need to be
looking at the rate well Pat let's do
that let's look at the rate of gun crime
of course thirty three thousand five
hundred ninety nine gun deaths in the US
with a population in 2014 of just under
319 million Japan with six that's zero
zero zero zero zero six just putting in
some zero placeholders there six gun
deaths with a population of 127 million
that means that the gun death rate in
the United States is twenty five hundred
not 2.5 not twenty five not 250 but
twenty five hundred times higher than in
Japan
well how easy is it to get a gun in
Japan you can get a gun but how easy is
it well let's look at the requirements
to get a gun in Japan you need to attend
an all-day class you need to then take a
written exam you need to pass a shooting
range test with a score of at least 95
percent you have to undergo a mental
health evaluation a drug test a criminal
record check police will then look into
whether you have any links to extremist
groups and then police may even check
into the links to extremist groups of
your relatives and your colleagues and
then once you pass all of that handguns
are banned only shotguns and rifles
allowed the number of gun stores per
precinct per area is limited you can't
have an unlimited supply of ammunition
when you finish you have to bring back
used cartridges in order to get more
ammunition but there's something else
which Japanese viewers who sent this
story to me
we're telling me about Japanese society
particularly in Tokyo puts huge pressure
on conformity and self control one need
only visit a subway station in Tokyo to
very quickly realize the importance of
self control and organization in Japan
committing an act of violence in Japan
would almost be seen as bringing shame
upon the perpetrator and even their
family there's this uh somebody I know
told me about this red tag system where
in Japan you have to recycle in a
particular way
certain types of trash and recycling
going different going different bins if
you misplace your recycling Rachel this
is gonna blow your mind the the company
that comes to pick up the trash and
recycling will red-tagged you one of you
the bin which basically publicly says to
anybody that goes by your bins this
person is not recycling correctly and
that is considered to bring shame it
would be embarrassing if that happens
that tells us a lot the culture around
guns in Japan tells us a lot about what
is going right there and what is going
wrong in the u.s. it does I think it
also might have started in World War two
when they were the the only ones who are
a victim of a nuclear attack and I think
that made them have kind of a more
sensitive approach to violence in
general that's interesting yeah I didn't
I didn't consider that and I mean there
are a number of contrasts in addition to
that for example Pat contrast the you if
you look at the gun culture in the u.s.
not only is gun culture in the u.s. very
different than in Japan for political
reasons but you have when somebody uses
a gun to kill someone else right almost
no matter what the circumstances are no
matter how depraved or insane you will
have some defenders now yes if it's a
ten out of state out of ten in terms of
insanity of how you use the gun to kill
someone you would probably have few
defenders but even in the case of what
we might rank as an
eight out of ten and how in the seigneur
use of a gun was to kill someone you
will have defenders in the United States
and that is a significant contrast to
what you see in Japan when people use
guns to kill people
yeah and part of that does have to do
with Japanese culture but it also has to
do with their restrictions and
regulations being a lot more rigorous
than what we have here and when you look
at that list I mean some of them may not
be so much in keeping with the American
tradition I don't think a lot of people
are going to get behind a written test
to obtain a weapon why not so much so
much of them are reasonable you have to
do a written test I mean I guess it's on
a computer now but it's it's it's it's
still written just not on paper if
you're going to drive right and cars
have a purpose
you could run someone over with a car or
a truck as we're increasingly seeing in
terrorist incidents but you might just
use a car for transportation and you
still have to have a written test why
does it not make sense to have a written
test for gun ownership in this country
it doesn't make sense because if you
think about the immediacy of how a car
can kill someone it's very similar to a
gun but another another point about the
the gun laws there is that if you're a
perpetrator of gun violence you're not
just committing one crime you're
committing three for owning the gun for
owning the bullets and for firing the
gun so even at that basic level you're
in a worse position in terms of the law
you're saying in Japan yep oh right well
I mean assuming that you have one of the
guns that's not allowed right because
handguns are not allowed and yes we have
limits on ammunition of course if police
figure out you had way way more
ammunition than what you were allowed
there's a number of factors here and you
know people will hear us pat and they'll
say you guys are the gun grabbers like
Obama who by the way grab no guns more
guns purchased under President Obama
than arguably any president in history
but this is just about common sense or
yeah or they'll point out and say well
because they don't have many guns I'm
sure there's mass stabbings all over the
place in Japan there is one you can
point to in July of last year where
someone stabbed I think 19 people that
was the biggest mass act of violence
since World War two in that country it
was you know it was just the anomaly not
to mention by the way that mass
stabbings leave far fewer people dead
than mass shootings as we know okay
let's pause there we're
take a break I will talk to Joel Whitney
next make sure to give us a like on
Facebook at facebook.com slash David
Pakman show Gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s